leute der tat dass das gerade irgendwie
gestoppt weil ich dann die kennen wir
die testversion habe aber das ist jetzt
egal ich würde sagen wir machen einfach
mal direkt weiter und zwar beim quartier
stehen geblieben bei dem lied ihr nehmt
einfach eine konstante leistung packt
die hier hinten rein
die findet ihr übrigens auch noch hier
in den audio überblendungen by crossgate
es hier die konstante leistung
allerdings habe ich mir ein paar sachen
raus gewählt wie zum beispiel diese
ganzen sachen hier also eine ihres
blender habe ich eine konstante leistung
wegdrehen wegschieben weiche blendet
übergangs zu schwarz also das sind meine
benutzerdefinierten die ich halt immer
verwende oder packt einfach eine
konstante leistung rein also das wird
dann schon ein bisschen anders aus am
ende und so weiter also es blendet sich
so ein bisschen aus aber es immer noch
ganz laut deswegen gehen wir rechtsklick
audio verstärkung - 33 mache ich
eigentlich immer hört ihr schon neuen
folge heute in der situation wollten wir
uns ja um die monster fälle kümmern und
so weiter also das hört man jetzt nur
noch ein ganz bisschen dann meine stimme
mache ich immer mit audio verstärkung
von 2 also dass sich halt ein bisschen
lauter bin heute ihr seht da schon wenn
ihr mal hier rechts achtet und wollten
wir uns ja um die monster falle wenn das
hier oben im orangen bereich ist es
alles gute sollte nicht ganz los sein
und es sollte nicht bei -18 sein sondern
immer so - drei ungefähr hier
das ist eigentlich so die perfekten
werte nun ist das video eigentlich schon
fertig und jetzt kommen wir noch so die
einzigen nachbearbeitung gemacht zum
beispiel hinten den übergang zur schwarz
reimann sieht das so aus sodass blendet
sich dann halt aus dann können wir am
anfang noch das intro machen wir wählen
dann einfach immer besser aus
zum beispiel nehme ich jetzt einfach mal
diese szene das ist jetzt natürlich
keine beste szene sondern macht das
einfach mal so mit diesem cutting tool
vorträge und dann habe ich jetzt
ausgewählt nämlich den pfeil markiert
das drücke steuerung c zurück nun
steuerung hat sie das ganze nach hinten
drückt wieder steuerung verfügt das hier
vorne ein macht dann das intro das sind
lang gleich aufgefallen so warte ich
mach das mal ganz kurz wieder ein
bisschen weiter nach hinten
da kommt man das intro hier löschen und
lücke schließen und dann nehme ich hier
mal eine ihres plänen und packte hier
ändern sieht das image ihres blende so
sieht das so aus
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
sind natürlich alles ein bisschen blöd
gekettet weiß seite und testen also dann
hier am anfang bei der szene auch mal
übergang zu schwarze mache ich einfach
ein bisschen kleiner
und hier unten auch eine konstante
leistung ich auch ein bisschen kleiner
mache so heute in der segways also das
ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen blöd so
dann haben wir noch hier die twitter
anmerkung facebook anmerkung facebook
anmerkung mache ich immer so am anfang
aber das ist jetzt natürlich alles ein
bisschen komisch weil der clip total
klein ist aber so mache ich das dann
eigentlich immer und zwar seht ihr schon
weil ich hier meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen da kommt die
facebook anmerkung reingeflogen das habe
ich mit acht effekt gehabt da kommende
twitter anmerkung die bleibt ein
bisschen drin die schiebt sich jetzt
gleich wieder raus so und diese
anmerkung dass es einfach nur ein bild
dann mache ich immer eine wegschieben
animationen vorne rein und hinten rein
also so die kommt also rein da sage ich
dann ja gibt einen hof es euch gefallen
hat daumen runter wenn nicht dann kommt
das jedoch aus also so ist dann mein
video dann geht das hier halt noch so
bis zum ende und dann was ich dann mache
ist einfach wartet dafür nehme ich
einfach kurz twitter und die diese
anmerkung hier weg damit das normal
gerendert werden kann jetzt mache ich
datei exportieren medien und nun hier
format h 264 vorgabe hd 720 habe ich mir
schon um abgespeichert findet ihr
allerdings auch moment hd 720 findet ihr
auch hier unten hd 720 einmal 25 und
29,9 7 nehmt einfach hd 720 29 97 dann
habt ihr hier die ganzen aufnahmen dass
ihr lasst ihr alles so wie es ist er
geht nur auf video und seht unten
schon hier die ziele betraten megabytes
pro sekunde
die könnt ihr wenn das video besser sein
soll natürlich auf 11 packen dann ist es
in ultra hd oder ganz normal auf 6
lassen also ich lasse sie immer auf 6
dann ist die qualität für mich in
ordnung und dann ist das ganz gut dass
hier unten ist ganz egal das könnt ihr
auch weit herunterdrehen das ist ganz
egal eigentlich so hier könnt ihr
aufgabe name geben hier habt ihr schon
die neuen lost folge wasteland thesdorf
name speichern
nun klickt einfach auf exportieren mit
diesen einstellungen kamen viele leute
einfach nicht klar weise das nicht
genauso machen konnten wie ich habe ich
viele nachrichten zu bekommen deswegen
mache ich das ja jetzt gerade befolgt
doch so wie ich es mache oder schreibt
eine sache in die kommentare und ja dann
hat sich das eigentlich schon das war
erstmal so grob das ganze wie ich
aufnehme natürlich wenn ich aufgenommen
habe und nicht dazu quatschen mussten
geht das alles ganz schnell mit
optischen und karten und ja alles und
das weiß natürlich auch blöd dass die
aufnahme relativ kurz verwegen den
anmerkungen und naja jedenfalls können
wir das ja jetzt eigentlich schließen
nein das möchte ich nicht speichern
diese beiden dateien ganz ausschließen
so da kann uns das mal angucken
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
heute in der segways land wollten wir
uns ja um die monster ferlemann und so
weiter
so sieht dann ein clip von mir geändert
aus also den habe ich ihnen hier und den
lade ich dann einfach auf youtube hoch
das heißt ich gegen mein bruder youtube
hochladen und so weiter
das war nun ein video wie ich aufnehme
ich habe das ganze grab mit ban die cam
aufgenommen das waren jetzt 15 minuten
genau ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
bewertet das video doch einfach mit
einem daumen hoch wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann runter wendig es hat für mich
lange gekostet das alles so
vorzubereiten ich habe hier zettel und
alles liegen hier wie ich das alles
vorbereitet so wie ich das ihr euch
vortrage und so weiter von daher würde
ich mich echt über eine positive
bewertung freuen fragen könnt ihr mir
die kommentare schreiben und dann würde
ich sagen will sehen uns dann nachher
bei der neuen der trendfolge zschau